a new frontier in ethiopia's war
rebels in tigray say they are advancing
further south towards the capital addis
ababa
the federal government has declared a
nationwide state of emergency
decree orders the state to have the
right to detain or arrest anyone
suspected of working with or assisting
the terrorist group
the emergency order dictates that
without permission granted from a
designated authority there is to be no
gathering or public protest allowed
prime minister abe ahmed has asked all
ethiopians to mobilize and fight back
against the rebels
there are many challenges but i can tell
you with certainty without a doubt we
will score a comprehensive victory in
just a few days the rebels from the
northern tigris state say they have
seized the towns of desai and kombolcha
which are in the neighboring amhara
state
the two are on a major highway leading
to the capital
the federal government has disputed
those claims
we have to make sure that our children
are not dying from hunger and services
we have to make sure that there is
access to medicine access to food by our
people so we'll do what it takes to make
sure that the siege is broken if we're
going to add this marketing to others is
what it takes to break the siege we will
the united states has warned the tigrai
people's liberation front or the tplf
against any such move let me be clear
we oppose
any tplf move to attis
or any attempt by the tplf to besiege at
us
there are concerns that violence could
escalate with tigrane rebels joining
forces with the oromo liberation army an
armed group in the region surrounding
the capital others there is a new
marriage of convenience alliance
between
at least a faction of the
oromo liberation front
and the tplf
because abbey has managed to alienate
the oromo
the including samharas so he is really
increasingly isolated and the tplf is
trying to take advantage of that
situation as well as ola
and its families like these who are
paying the highest price for the
shifting battle lines of ethiopia's war
that's dragged on for nearly a year
more than two and a half million people
have been forced to leave their homes
and around 400 000 are on the brink of
famine
priyanka gupta al jazeera